i don't know that's things it's just i
disagree with them
if you disagree with their orthodoxy
then you get into trouble i mean look at
covet i've disagreed with most the
kovitch yet i was right about all of it
but you were right about all of it yeah
what were you right about that everybody
said i said it i said this effects
this affects the elderly and it affects
sick people but it doesn't really do
anything to kids or young people which
it doesn't i've complained against but
isn't there aren't there young people
and kids that have gotten incredibly ill
from it yeah
but that doesn't mean we need to shut
society down
so you were against just a totally the
shutdown shutting down schools for
instance i was against it doesn't really
affect kids right so
now the the argument of like
well hasn't it affected some kids yeah
um there's 19 year old boys who probably
got prostate cancer or something at some
point but doesn't mean we build the
protocol around okay i'm going to have
an argument right now yeah she's she's a
lot more woke
no but even if it doesn't affect kids
i'm not arguing with your thought
process and i think you're right for the
most part it doesn't affect kids and
people who are healthy if they have
a sibling or a parent or a grandparent
or whatever at home that they're taking
care of isn't it our responsibility
before we have treatment or before we
have a vaccine or before any of that
when it's brand new and it is affecting
people to kind of look out for one
another
yeah except for
this fallacy of like
we live with our elderly grandparents or
we live this isn't italy from 1941.
i have elderly parents i don't live with
them i don't know anyone who lives with
their elderly parents or else did you
keep you but here's what i'm trying to
keep your kids away from your parents
they don't even like my
that was done and done yeah
so you were trying to get them you're
trying to push them over there
no what i'm saying is
these are these scenarios where okay it
doesn't affect the kids but what if the
kid gets infected and then they visit
nana or papi and then they get them
that's all a possibility but you can't
build a protocol around this possibility
like that's not a reason to shut schools
down that's a reason for you to go you
can't visit your grandparents or you
have to they can say do it with a mask
or from the different different side of
the living room yeah i mean my fear has
always been
you know passing it on or giving it to
my dad or my mom or going and visiting
my grandparents in canada that's always
been my fear i wasn't allowed to see her
or the kids first that was the plan the
plan was to scare the [ __ ] out of
everybody yeah i mean i'm always scared
anyways your wife is your wife on the
same page as you
sort of kind of
maybe
nobody was on the same page as me you
live in california yeah i was like they
tried to shut down the horse trails
around my house they were shutting down
the beaches i was like [ __ ] this
immediately and immediately so if you're
well so here's how i knew what was going
on they weren't giving the ages of
people who died
that was the big problem that's what
caught me originally they weren't
telling us how old the people who died
were they were just saying a man in our
leader died of of covet but well we
didn't know we but we all knew that
the majority of deaths were
overweight unhealthy elderly people
that's not the majority of americans
have underlying health issues it was the
secret here's what they did in in my
estimation although
the statistics bore this out or bear
this out
they
they wouldn't initially tell us it was
basically people in
nursing homes that were dying they
didn't initially do that isn't that what
but i i beg to differ isn't that
initially what they were doing because i
remember the nursing homes the first
time we heard of it starting was wasn't
in seattle that like all these people
were dying
it was the nursing homes yeah people
were dying in nursing homes for sure
they they died in you know
vastly higher percentages in nursing
homes because they're elderly and they
were compromised but they didn't really
say
this is what's happening so
they were simultaneously saying people
are dying in nursing homes and shutting
schools
my thing is is if people are dying in
nursing homes you don't need to shut
schools they never needed to shut
schools i think it was the unknown at
the beginning right yeah at the
beginning but they carried that into the
like a year and a half into it
that's that's my argument i think they
were un
they're unduly scaring the population
they never really made a separation like
that the notion that like
well it disproportionately affects the
elderly it's not even disproportionate
it's it's minuscule what it does to
young people like they should have
really hammered that home like hey if
you're healthy and you're under 30 this
thing's not going to touch you it's just
not going to affect you like it would
affect an elderly person then they never
drove that home
is that true though
are there not some healthy young people
that have been statistically doesn't
exist like deaths for young people see
we don't we still don't really know this
no i don't know
it's not something they're pushing out
but do you know that they were healthy i
do know they were healthy
well i know the family yeah it's one
person
we can't construct a society around one
person and that's that's my argument
that's why did you get in trouble for
this argument
well yeah i told i i said i can do
whatever i want i'm deathly scared of
flying and i don't know anyone who's
dead and playing
yeah
but that's what you're making here i
know i'm just saying you're saying that
you can't anyone could be scared of
anything no but there's no reason but i
think there's more reason to be scared
of an unknown illness that's affecting a
nation and there were a lot of deaths
proven death not with young people who
are healthy but but we do have look it
up go look you've got a computer well
why do we have a million deaths over a
million deaths we have a lot of old fat
people
we do
okay but then don't you have to take
care of the rest of the uh the us
you don't have to shut a school system
down to take care of overweight elderly
people so you're only
no but he's making sense okay all right
no no don't fall no no i'm not gonna
fight we're on opposing ends of the
spectrum here and it's fine and i really
believe that everyone is
my point was that espec i agree with you
now we probably we should not have
closed schools for as long as we did
but i
think he wasn't against closing schools
at the beginning right it's just yes
right away never for a moment oh well i
would have closed them for two weeks or
something but right now eventually but
it took us almost a year to get
any kind of grasp on handling the
situation or getting a vaccine or
getting a
treatment no i'm saying the powers that
be had a grasp on this earlier than we
did and they did not inform us of this
that might be so but the people
locally who had to make decisions who
maybe didn't have the information that
you're saying
the powers that be had that didn't pass
it along had to do with what they had to
do with the information they had well
look there's two disneylands there's one
in florida there's one in california the
one in california was closed the whole
time the one in florida was open most
the time they could have figured it out
if the one in florida is doing okay
maybe we could open the one in
california but we wouldn't do it in
california
we wouldn't open schools this is not my
podcast dad go for it i'm just gonna i i
i'm interested i'm interested in the in
the two sides of this
i don't wanna argue i didn't want to
come on here and argue with a guest
you're not arguing i'm not really
arguing you're not and you're
respectfully you're respectfully i
respect everyone's opinion i really do i
just have a different opinion well
that's fine but if your opinion has
closed the beach down in my opinion is i
want to go to the [ __ ] beach then i
should go to the beach i agree with you
i agree but he wasn't allowed to but i
wasn't allowed to go to the beach
because at the beginning we didn't know
they never look you're not an
epidemiologist if you can't [ __ ]
figure out that going to the beach is
not a bad place to go with a virus
that's insane but i'm not an
epidemiologist and i was just going
based on what i did know you listened to
people that shut the beaches down i
didn't listen to them i knew they were
wrong and they were wrong
[Music]